derelict paradise homelessness and Urban
Development at cleveland ohio where he
seeks answers to the question who
benefits from homelessness the book
examines Cleveland's history male 19th
century through the early twenty-first
Kerr is currently working on a
manuscript addressing the research he
conducted with the Cleveland
homelessness oral history project we
interviewed close to 200 homeless people
and facilitated dozens of workshops and
meetings shelters and drop-in centers of
Cleveland he addresses a spark in detail
in the article we know what the problem
is in the oral history review published
in the winter spring edition of 2003 and
tonight we're going to talk about how
oral history can facilitate movement
building focusing on his work with the
Cleveland homeless oral history project
Daniel Kerr will examine how oral
history research can be on professional
and academic aims and actively
facilitate social change rather than
pursuing one more study of extreme
poverty from afar he embraced oral
history as a technique to foster
structured dialogue among unhoused
people so that they could come to a
greater understanding
their own condition they did so not only
by giving their own interviews but by
listening to and interpreting the
narrative of other project participants
collective reflection became inseparable
from collective action as HOH p
participants utilize the power of their
stories as a tool to transform the world
around them um-hmm actually it's chopped
I like acronyms like no it is CH 0 HP
but I i choose acronyms oh like yeah can
I used to be involved in a group called
the squatter theatre action brigade and
that acronym was stabbed chop was kind
of like it calling it Chum so just can I
just get a quick sense I know many of
you have at least read one of my
articles within the class for today but
how many folks are familiar with or have
read any of my work that way I know how
much background I need to do versus not
if you're not familiar haven't read my
work would you mind raising your hand
just okay okay I'll just assume that you
don't I won't assume you know that way
it'll be better so all right um this is
a project really what I'd like to do is
I take a couple steps back before I get
into how oral history can facilitate
movement building which I do want to
have a discussion in terms of today and
in the future hopefully we can open that
up
also to dialogue moving forward but
obviously in order to do this
presentation I also have to talk about
my past experience with oral history so
I'm going to focus a good hunk of this
presentation on a Cleveland homeless
oral history project and the work that
was done there and just some of the
evolution that was been there in the
practice that I embraced through that
project I came to that project actually
first working as an activist primarily
interested in issues of housing just a
my Cashin was in dressing issues of
housing and I was fascinated by the
squatters movement and ultimately
participated in it in the lower east
side for three years where the the goal
was really to take over abandoned
buildings and create housing it's a very
direct approach to dealing with this and
we had we literally built barricades us
from 13th Street fictions 1995 may 1995
we literally built barricades and to try
and protect the buildings one of the
things I learned however is that in
order to get to a point where you
actually build a barricade on the street
face down thousands of riot police
there's a lot of storytelling that goes
on before that you know people don't
just go out on the street and build a
barricade without telling a lot of
stories and so really the side of the
squatters movement that influenced me in
terms of understanding movements was all
those down times hanging out on park
benches and on Stoops where people told
the history both the history and their
stories frequently not their life
stories as I'll get into shortly but
various stories about neighbor
neighborhood transformation their
analysis their historical analysis as to
how things were and why they were the
way they were as well as their
prescriptions for change that were
debated in those particular spaces
really intrigued me there was no
research I didn't perceive myself as a
research and a researcher and I wasn't
interested in documentation or being a
documentarian I was really envisioning
myself as a participant okay and so it
was a pretty significant change moving
from the Lower East Side to cleveland
ohio for many reasons it was a
deliberate intentional move one was I
was really seeking to get away from kind
of a place where people go to be cool
and activists him on and people don't
really well there's actually some
exceptions to this rule don't go to the
homeless shelters of Cleveland to be him
and so it just seemed to me one of the
more unhip places I could think about
and that's in part what motivated me to
try and explore place
where I could work with folks who were
were not necessarily well okay now I'm
just leave that out so the second thing
and i should say when i write shortly
before i left the lorry side i had
multiple multiple students both
undergrad and grad students come and
interview me and so i figured i was
really deliberately trying to escape
academia to a large extent through
participation in a squatters movement
and i figured i had really done it when
i become the subject of research in
particular when an anthropology student
was interviewing me but i decided that
there there was in particular relevance
to research if it was done as a popular
in the model of popular education and i
realized that there was quite a bit of
research that was going into the
activism that was taking place in the
lower east side and that there were a
lot of folks that were not squatters
that were really at the backbone of the
squatters movement and so I didn't have
to be homeless in Cleveland live in the
shelter in order to play a role and
actually addressing the conditions books
were in and developing solidarity with
folks who were living in the shelter
that's what I was interested in but I
was going to instead of taking an
activist approach embraced the idea of
popular educators such as Paulo Freire
miles Horton who really argued who
really argue that we need to let people
define what the issues are themselves
that as you probably or maybe you can't
see ismail horton so this is very
important that you understand the
difference between your perception of
what people's problems are and their
perception of them right so rather than
going to cleveland and saying okay we're
going to take over abandoned buildings
because this is what i understood as a
relevant solution from coming as a
squatter to Cleveland
I very deliberately wanted to see what
folks how folks perceive their own
problems and lives from this situation
there on standpoint the idea of praxis
was one that i was in particularly i was
particularly intrigued by because i
thought there was a lot of action and
activism going on in the squatters
movement that did not incorporate a lot
of reflection critical reflection and so
the very idea of praxis which is really
movement where reflection and movement
are intertwined inextricably intertwined
was one that I found extraordinarily
compelling how do we create spaces where
people can reflect and move through the
very process of reflection right and so
it's not one after the other it's
literally as Paulo Freire argues
simultaneous and so I also was very
interested in Palo fairs idea of
generative themes which is similar to I
think what mile is miles Horton is
getting that in his quote above that and
the idea of generative themes being
letting folks again generate the themes
that are shaping their lives that are
relevant for their lives on play a role
in that process right rather than me
define those themes for them and so
those were were pretty core to shaping
my interest in setting up the Cleveland
homeless oral history project it started
off really with a program food not bombs
that I initiated in Cleveland I had been
involved in a free food program in
Lori side where we would gather and
prepare food and share it in a park and
so when I moved to Cleveland as
interested in the potential for food to
bring people together in particular not
as a form of charity this was the the
food was shared really as a picnic style
help yourself picnic style where people
would come we were not originally
planning to set up on public square in
downtown Cleveland we went around and
tried a bunch of different places but we
settled in on public square because at
the time we were bringing the food down
which was on a Sunday afternoon public
square happened to be right in the
middle of the public library and tower
city which is we're basically people who
are enhanced move from the library as it
closes down at 5pm and walk across
public square to this mall in particular
when there's bad weather it's also a
central point for all of the bus
stations a lot of the bus stops are on
central square our public square so the
food was brought down and this was
originally brought down in January of
1996 now one one thing I can say is that
that program is going on every has been
going on every week every Sunday since
january of 1996 is still going on and is
played a role with the occupation
movement in Cleveland on the Food Not
Bombs folks oh well I might not have
shaped everything I think that that
still does continue and so folks started
gathering mmm around the food and
creating spaces to kind of talk and
reflect people came from different walks
of life it was this kind of central
meeting space a public space
you know different age groups that
brought different degrees of knowledge
and expertise about the changes within
the city this Ralph Williams pack who
came to the city in nineteen forty I
believe in 1945 if I remember correctly
and has lived downtown basically his
whole life right others who came to the
meal included Robert Jackson and Bob
mulchen would become core participants
within a lot of the movements that were
product of this oral history project so
mmm original so basically from 96 until
nineteen ninety nine every week I'm
going downtown and hanging out and
eating with folks and talking to people
in what I at least refer to as good of a
hanging out mode okay sharing
experiences I talking to him telling my
stories as well as listening to their
stories talking about just basic things
such as the weather and the various
sports events but also talking about
politics both near and far and that
played I think a central role in shaping
the evolution of project so that when I
do eventually in 1999 bring down the
video camera I think at least
understanding this process of developing
those relationships essential to
understanding how this project unfolds I
did start off in that very first year
doing for life histories okay I was
interested in the idea that oral history
could I could develop some techniques I
was interested in public popular
education and I was thinking about very
specifically about how oral history
could play a role in popular education
and I really couldn't conceive of oral
history
is anything different the life history
okay and so I interviewed these four
individuals and each of them just told
me devastating stories that really ended
in just with a just sense of despair
there was a clear sense of longing for
death they were necrophilic narratives
they folks sought to distinguish
themselves from other homeless in order
to talk about how they were different
from those those people it was done I
thought there were folks who at a
certain point in time when guy I
interviewed us just stopped and said you
know what he was talking about his
addiction to crack cocaine he said no
what there's nothing in this for me
let's just stop this interview right now
right because because this was also a
narrative they were familiar with
because when they went through the
intake procedures at the shelter when
they tried to access social services
that had to tell a story about their
lives their life history and how create
a narrative in terms of how they're
trying to create personal individual
transformation right which was
frequently done through distinguishing
themselves from those people who are not
trying to create personal transformation
right and so it shocked me that this
wasn't going to go very far like in
terms of movement building certainly and
that the actual framing of the interview
itself was in part the problem I do
think contrary to many folks that that
the interviewer plays a significant role
in framing the narrative okay in terms
of how the interview structure so I was
perceived as the audience the idea was I
was going to take these interviews back
and I was going to analyze and reflect
on them and they were not going to be
shared with other people who lived
alongside the people who are doing
interviews and so when I indicated to
them that I was interested in creating a
zine where there's in
use would be shared with others none of
them would consent to allowing their
names to be attached to the interviews
okay and so they did consent to the
interviews being shared but they didn't
want their names attached so I decided
to move to a different model altogether
just completely drop this idea of what
oral history was and instead i bought a
TV I don't know if you can see these
slides at all can you not sure if
there's a dimmer run yeah I'm not
reading but I can't see you though okay
so we might want to turn down when I
showed the video but so what I did was I
brought down a TV this is it a trick I
learned as a squatter and I found I
first identified a plug outlet on public
square so I brought down my TV with a
inexpensive VCR and the first time I did
this I just brought a documentary dark
days I don't know if you've seen it
about that folks living in the tunnels
of New York but the main reason I
brought that wasn't just so people could
watch TV but because I wanted to
demonstrate that this is the space where
your interview is going to be shown
right so people would know exactly who
their audience was and that their
audience was going to be and people
would be able to connect their face to
their words and their narrative other
folks who were also homeless unhoused
living alongside them in the shelter and
then outside and the camps and so I
brought down the video camera and said I
asked them all so instead of their life
stories I ask them I'm going to show you
a video here
I asked them to explain their analysis
of the causes of homelessness the
history and causes of homelessness right
so I wanted instead to ask instead of
asking them you know tell me about your
childhood tell me what what are the
causes of homelessness how did
homelessness come to be right and that's
what they were past when they is set up
here's just one and I mean I'm showing
you this one for a particular reason
because this interview was the most
popular interview in all the workshops I
did later I'll talk briefly about why in
this case mmm the narrator actually
incorporates Jose Jimenez appropriates
that the character Jose Jimenez who was
a character utilized by Bill Dana in the
1960s understood now I have to look for
my my material here bill vaina
essentially took this real a
stereotypical image of a Puerto Rican
that was largely disparaging and I think
it's kind of interesting that he
appropriates this image and I think
reinterprets that as I'll talk about
briefly so here's the the interview
my name Jose Jimenez truth is my name is
none of your business so you
might to tell me but me no way I would
like their mind right now what's on my
mind is the truth I see on Jay avenue
and up on huff Avenue they're forcing
out the poor and the lower middle class
with one two and three hundred dollar
thousand three hundred thousand dollar
homes you know what else they're
doing the privatizing prisons who take
contracts from people like Sony Toyota
won't Nissan same difference mercedes
republic steal
and then they put all these poor people
in these privatized prisons because they
can't afford to live anywhere because
they're building all these one two and
three hundred thousand dollar homes in
my city and all my people are going to
jail because they don't make 50,000
dollars a year they all have to
work for the temporary services to buy
cigarettes to buy their beer you don't
have to worry about beer all you got to
worry about it's paying your house note
and paying your lexus note you come pay
my bills man
you come pay my bills the truth is that
nobody that is poor or lower middle
class is going to be living in the city
they're all going to be living in a
privatized prisons because they're all
vagrants they ain't got a hundred bucks
in their pocket you see you come build
these cities and all these homeless
people and all these poor people are
going to jail to make all you guys money
you come build these cities come build
these towns with my fascination these
beautiful homes down on j Avenue and
down on tough happening beautiful
gorgeous mansions in the heart of the
ghetto yeah you make the poor people go
nowhere because they can't go to the
suburbs and they can't stay in the city
it's called a field of schemes not a
field of dreams
come live in my world one time you roll
this garden grow this garden with my
brothers and sisters and let's see if
you can stand up one more time
little girl all right so why this is
just one but i think it's interesting
example you know this one of the reasons
why i think that it was so compelling is
because he makes so little effort to
kind of establish a credibility through
you know he's not wearing a shirt he's
he's very confrontational you know he's
not going to talk about how I don't
drink that much he's very deliberately
saying yeah I drink but so do you you
know and and you come pay for my bills
and there's a question of who he's
talking to you know this framing of who
is the audience here and how he's kind
of moving back and forth one is he's
talking to this kind of imagined yuppie
audience right but he's very also
deliberately performing for the unhoused
audience that's kind of immediately
watching him and that will watch him the
next week on that TV I just showed you I
think he's also talking to me right so
he you know stands up literally kind of
just asserting this hyper masculinity
and kind of feminizing and and
infantilizing this ambiguous other so
you know kind of referencing these
popular cultural forms and you know in
the end I say all right there's
certainly a degree of kind of confusion
acknowledgement of what he said but also
what do I do with all of this right and
so
Hartley is just figuring out one okay
how do I analyze this but but really to
me the important aspects were and I will
talk about this and analyze it but the
important aspects were also to create
spaces where other folks could sit back
and reflect on these interviews okay and
just so just remember that interview for
a second and I'm going to come back and
refer to it but you can well I suppose I
might as well just highlight them right
now so that you can remember better but
there are numerous instances where he's
kind of making gestures and very bodily
referencing the physical space around
him using you know referring to huff and
Jay Avenue and the very kind of act of
standing up is to some extent a movement
that I think is significant I'll explain
why later there's bodily movements
within the actual interview performance
a very performative interview as you can
see which is largely why it's so popular
but that's some in addition to kind of
that scaling of the scaling of who he's
talking to the kind of use of that
public space and ultimately kind of
reinterpretation this occupation and
reinterpretation of the space which is
ultimately a hostile space that they're
turning into and making their own okay
it's a space where they face police
harassment and brutality to space where
they're referring to dis possessions in
various neighborhoods that are nearby in
the downtown business district but it's
also a space that they utilize for their
own kind of survival and everyday lives
and that they're shaping into their
space food is bringing these
conversations as well together so
instead of me just sitting around and
interpreting it he knew that was going
to be played oops we got
back to this uh these slides are not
really working quite well okay this is
an image of the workshop so the basic
idea was to show the workshops show
these interviews in workshop setting
several workshops that were organised at
local drop-in centers where meals are
served where people can hang out during
the day where people get clothes take
showers etc also in the shelters
frequently what I've found is that the
best relationships in order to these
were also viewed as hostile spaces by
the narrator's these were not friendly
spaces in fact as I'll get into the
biggest most significant critique that
emerges out of the workshops as a major
theme is the degradation everyday
degradation people are facing within the
shelter within their home life and so
utilizing these spaces really also is
about kind of redefining those spaces
and and taking over to some extent those
spaces that required a lot of networking
with staff frequently at the lowest
levels of the hierarchy are sometimes
the ones that are the best ones to
organize and work with in order to
something I learned from trying to
solicit food donations is you don't ask
the manager of a grocery store for
produce produce you ask the produce the
person who works in the produce section
who is in charge of throwing that stuff
out right to set it aside and this is
the same thing in in order to get access
to these facilities but gradually we
develop those relationships as well with
people were working in these spaces who
allowed us to use these basis for the
workshops and the themes that were
developed included six of them not in
any particular order here the first
being the transformation
downtown's okay so lots of these
interviews talk about the rise of the
new stadium sports stadiums and
Convention Center that entailed the
demolition of the Skid Row hotels the
former flophouse districts and how this
was a significant loss an autonomous
living situation relatively autonomous
living situation that has now been
superseded by a highly controlled
shelter system number two had to be was
this reinterpretation of neighborhood
Renaissance you heard that in that
interview one of the reasons again why
that interview was so popular is because
it cuts across many of these different
themes and really talking about the
dispossession and the transformation of
the neighborhoods that folks grew up in
within those neighborhoods and gives us
a very different perspective and
ultimately their perspective really kind
of bears itself out as Cleveland becomes
the epicenter of the foreclosure crisis
in 1997 it really at the Cleveland in
Detroit have closed you know nearly half
of the top 10 zip codes with the highest
rates of foreclosure leading into the
financial club so you know this story is
is not just a local one and meanwhile
the business leaders in the late 90s
we're talking about you know the
narrative was one of Renaissance and how
Cleveland's the comeback City and how
everything's being fixed up and cleaned
up after the
at the riots which turns out not to be
the one that really a kind of
effectively explains the reality the
expansion of the criminal justice system
right so he ties in the role of the
prisons here but the prisons are defined
as verily very closely intertwined with
the homeless shelters really homeless
shelters are seen as an extent extension
of the prison complex and I referred to
as open Penitentiary's jails prisons
repeatedly throughout the narratives
collapse of welfare which is really
defined as creating a greater dependency
on low-wage jobs and the rise of day
labor agencies which is linked to the
meltdown of wages so people are still
doing jobs and their part the most the
most common job they're doing this punch
press operator which in the 1950s was a
job in Cleveland that only white
machinist male machinist did and they
fought literally fought to keep
african-americans from doing that job
unionized machinists by the 1990s and
2000's for homeless african-american men
and women that's their most common job
it's working as a punch press on print
and then lastly the growth of the
shelter industries which is ultimately
seen as a loss of autonomy and this
becomes the two themes that emerged as
the ones that people are most interested
the generative themes that people are
most interested in addressing are the
degradation conditions within the
shelter's which is also linked to
maintaining their ability to stay out of
the shelters because there's kind of two
sides to that same thing and then the
second one is the exploitation of their
work in their work working lives okay so
two themes that I would not have really
focused on if I just came in as an
activist trying to tell folks what this
should deal with but these are the
themes that emerged
this out of this situation so in part
these workshops had taken place in the
shelter spaces and the project
increasingly defy expanded a lot of this
as relationships developed involve my
physically moving throughout more and
more spaces understanding getting a
greater sense of the geography of these
folks everyday lives so finding out the
spaces where people do congregate hang
out and talk right one of those spaces
is in the line in order to get into the
shelter long lines in order to get into
the shelter the long lines waiting to
get food once one is inside of the
shelter right and so almost always food
is like very actively presidents the
time when people have their food or just
finished eating where people these are
the places where people are having the
most significant reflective moments so
every single space where we have the
workshops where we're doing the actual
initial interviews where were having
discussions with in shelters are around
food ok so the shelter becomes the first
place of organizing they the protect
participants create a petition drive
literally to remove the people who are
operating the shelter which was a
Salvation Army and before that another
group called project heat which were
private non-profit institutions that
were running the shelter for the city
and county paid for by the city and
county so those kinds process of
privatization but mmm they created
significant changes within the shelter
they literally shut down project heat
which then led to the rise of a new mega
shelter that was run by the Salvation
Army then they ran the Salvation Army
out of the shelter after lots of
organizing and then ultimately they
demanded that they run the shelter but
that
they didn't dad demand men but they
ultimately had a new agency which at
least alleviated some of the most
degrading aspects of living there so
dealing with those very immediate living
conditions there was a group called the
Northeast Ohio Coalition for the
homeless who argued those weren't the
issues we should spend our time on right
but for the folks who are living in the
shelters these were the most important
issues that they should be spending
their time on so I thought that was
interesting and I should also say these
these are what I viewed as ends many of
the different ends of this overall oral
history project the petition you know
became an end a product of the oral
history project you know that was
informed by the oral histories and the
themes and ultimately i shaped these
movements ultimately one of the things
that kept on emerging as people were
talking more and more is that we need to
expand and amplify our voice is what the
word was and the homeless president
who's pictured here said we need to
establish an air war and this is how he
referred to a former former Vietnam
veteran and so we set up a radio show
that aired on the local college station
and these radio shows each one to some
extent became a product of the oral
history show they brought they each got
tapes they brought them back to the
shelter and the drop-in centers to play
these tapes to other folks people were
listening to these and what was
gradually happy happening was this move
from what I think is an apt way of
looking at this that James
anthropologist James Scott talks about
is moving from the hidden transcript to
the public transcript being able to
develop a sense of confidence that you
could say these things right this these
words where you would risk being cast
out of the shelter losing your job in an
increasingly public space
right where you could confront power
more and more directly right with this
very critical analysis and so the radio
show became significant nearly all the
participants in the radio show played a
very active role in many of the social
movements that developed the other side
that the radio show played a significant
role was protecting the homeless
encampments around town and and and
discussing these camps and the rationale
behind why people were living in the
camps and why they sought to preserve
what most folks saw as miserable living
conditions right done so this was one
space that eventually there's a major
movement that the homeless president
organizes and this this protest becomes
another end figuring out again as people
are expressing this protest to prevent
the demolition of what was known as
Camelot by the people who lived in this
building became a and because for me
what it meant was Val arising and and
supporting what folks wanted to do with
this project where they wanted to move
it and if they wanted to the project
meant that they wanted to prevent the
city from demolishing this building then
that would then become an end that I
would take time and effort to support so
this is an inside the building and in
this process I don't know you can't even
see this in so in this process on you
can in this picture the same person who
I'm interviewing is talking to the media
right and so what we start seeing again
is this implication of voices movement
from the hidden to the public transcript
we're here rather than me going to talk
to the media as organizing person the
folks who are doing the narrator's or
themselves speaking for themselves in
front of the media telling them what
their analysis of the causes and why
they're fighting and what are their
struggles right we see it the other
issue one
workshops and I should say I really
really have to stress this is not kind
of a uniform analysis that emerges among
the homeless it's really kind of a
recognition of the multiplicity of
voices very multi vocal and the the
movement here of people in the camps is
different than the movement of people
living in the shelter within the shelter
and there's tensions right but because I
this that one of the strengths of using
oral history process here of the process
of critical reflection is that in the
emergence of a what I view is a complex
critical analysis is that people can
start seeing while I may be fighting
here that is intertwined with your
struggle over there right and why we
might be fighting for slightly different
things that they're still interconnected
right and so this then becomes a way of
creating this more complex critical
consciousness through these workshops
spaces allows for these multiple
different movements kind of around
different issues kind of propping up and
one I should also say one of the efforts
to protect the folks who are living
outside emerges literally from that
space where the videos are done one week
the in the interview shortly after the
one that I did there and right before
Thanksgiving a person talks about how
they the mayor has instituted sweeps on
the streets to clear the homeless out
for the Christmas shopping season and so
there then as a discussion well what
should we do and people say we should
set up a camp on the mayor's lon we
should maybe set up a camp in front of
City Council and ultimately they decide
to set up an encampment right there on
the very same spot where the video
interview was being done which to me is
about again using kind of the very
bodily movements and they reclaiming the
space through the performance of the
interview in terms of redefining that
very physical space where that becomes a
space where the tent is located that
people are staying in
testing that becomes a very critical
moment undercutting the support for the
mayor and that in the city eventually
doesn't run for reelection not to say
and there's still now right now with the
re-emergence of the Occupy movement in
Cleveland they're still dealing with the
ramifications of this movement that you
know to not allow homeless to sleep on
the streets so mmm this of the
temporary day laborer agencies becomes
the other major theme in the group one
of the workshops literally forms into a
group called which eventually becomes a
day laborers organizing committee
dealloc and they organized to create
City Council hearings arguing that
sitting work work over 20 people testify
in front of City Council about their
grievances and they coordinate their
testimony ahead of time talking about
who's going to talk about what and what
are our major goals that we need to
communicate and what are we trying to
get out of this and they do these
testimonies on the day laborer industry
while representatives from the industry
are sitting in the audience okay so this
is really this creating of the space
where a movement from the hidden to the
public deliberately moving in that
moment with the City Council hearings
and and then you also have movements to
drive the labor agents out of the
shelters and so you know these this
becomes a new area of a new space where
another kind of aspect of this
multiplicity of ends and then lastly I
just want to say part of the strength
here in creating these spaces not to say
that all these discussions hadn't been
had but many of them been had been
talked about long before I had arrived
but bringing folks together from these
different across these different divides
you know from different camps from
different cliques within the shelter
different individuals that weren't
necessarily connected to a larger social
network within that shelter
to participate in this discussion and
then literally create movement from this
folks so it's bridging these divides
that through these spaces that were
crafted by these workshops that were set
up to analyze the oral history project
eventually these spaces expanded this is
a picture that was taken in Chicago you
can see those two same guys that I
showed you from very early on the one on
the far left and the one right here you
know had participated this project both
has done radio show and this is them in
Chicago added endl on national day
laborer organizing Network conference
that was primarily organized by Latino
day laborers from across the country and
hear what this ended up doing is craving
a space where for the folks that were
predominately african-american white and
puerto rican in cleveland moving to work
out work within these industrial sites
as day laborers frequently found
themselves working alongside latino day
laborers from lorain ohio and there was
a very hostile tense relationship so
figuring out ways again to start
expanding those in bridging those
divides across different barriers also
proved I thought to be a potentially
enormously powerful way that oral
history could build movements now this
was done by one graduate student with a
total budget of two thousand dollars
over a span nearly a decade okay this
was all done by my myself one of the
things that was the weakness of this is
that there wasn't a network of other
folks doing similar work like myself
that I could tap into to start creating
these devout bridging these divides so
for example if there had been not a
network you know in addition to Chicago
but folks doing similar work in Lorraine
with Latino day laborers within Lorraine
then we could create more
connections right if we had folks
working who were still housed in
Cleveland with people who are facing
potential foreclosure or people who were
housed and working within the day
laborer industry in Cleveland you know
in addition to folks that were housed
but were dealing with the stigmatization
of being ex-offenders in the community
that this would have created a
significant greater potential for
dressing these issues because all of
those themes that they laid out there
were not inherently homeless themes
right and so finding the waste to create
and establish these relationships and to
share that authority for interpretation
and reflecting critical reflection and
defining which ways to move forward
would have been strengthened if it
wasn't me doing this by myself in an
isolated situation so eventually I leave
as my graduate as I get my PhD I moved
to Washington DC and other than the Food
Not Bombs continuing to this day which
has largely been about sharing food not
about developing these conversations and
this this activity is largely disavow we
could have our you know what what should
have happened how come we're not doing
this anymore and so that was partly my
fault as well but I'm gonna open this up
for conversations and let you ask
questions and make comments I think I
probably spoke way too